gate yeah between attention from Men
that says you're [__] sexy
opposed to I want to make you my wife
100 yes no no but I'm saying do you
think women know how to differentiate it
hang on wait wait Linda Linda go on I
don't think so why
because
they don't yeah because they a lot of
like a lot of women you know they look
for guys that are smooth that I have
game and guys know that sex is a lot
except a lot more accessible now than it
was in the past so they they like I know
of guys uh I I know some guy friends
that I probably shouldn't say that I
know that I associate with but like they
say that they'll go to bars and they'll
say they're a lawyer they're a doctor
and get in bed and then they're actually
just working at Walmart you know so I
think yeah I don't think they
differentiate it well I think women have
a very hard time differentiating
attention from men yeah I I think one of
the reasons why you may think you're an
8.5 is because you get a lot of
attention from men right but but the
attention that you're getting from men
is because they want to [__] you I'm
just going to be realistic
let me tell you let me tell you
men are aesthetic creatures yeah let me
just try and give you some game about
men men are aesthetic creatures right we
will see a nice ass pretty face some
round tits right and we would say oh my
God that is attractive right and women
will feel that attention and be like oh
my God he thinks I'm attractive but he
thinks you're attractive because he
wants to [__] you not because he wants
to make his wife yeah it's not because
he wants to make you make it a mother of
his children it's not because he wants
to put you inside his home and keep you
there for the rest of his life it's
because he wants to get into your
coochie yeah all right let me let me say
it you need to learn to differentiate
between the two you ask me about my
physical rating I said 8.5
and you and you said it's going to go up
when you get money but it doesn't it
doesn't matter if you have money because
you can't buy Youth and once you and
once you hit 30 you're down a point well
you see yeah
my surgery
that's the thing like like this is this
is Kylie Jenner looks scary she like
when you see her in person like that's
not attractive I'll tell you why money
and a lot of times like women they get
the botox they get the fillers but like
men can see it like they see your face
moving weird you see you're 100 and it
signals to them that like you're you're
uh for fun instead of a wife okay and so
you could get the money you could get
the surgeries but you can't buy youth
you can't buy Purity so so are you
really in the top let me explain to you
because that's an assumption that I'm
going to use the money to to do surgery
and do things the reason why if I'm
Richard you know why I'll be hotter
because I want it hard to who to the
world no men and women I'll tell you why
let me explain to you why and I'll tell
you just one of the major problems that
you have listen do you know what money
buys money buys you time that means that
if I'm rich 90 of your eggs are gone
that's okay but I'm talking about why I
talk about being hot right if I got
money I'm by myself time in the sense
that I don't have to do half of the
things that I would have had to to do
before I have a nutritionist if I want
to oh it's fine okay let me finish let
me finish well let me finish because it
makes sense there's a calculation to
this if I got money I can buy and I can
get a nutritionist or Chef which means
my diet is going to be better which
means that my skin will look better
because I'm eating better quality food
and means that I'm eating the right food
I can go to the gym more means my body
how did you become this deluded
you know what a lot of the celebrities
that are out there that look amazing and
everybody think they're beautiful and
they're so hot and every man wants that
girl it just even if it's Justified
because we're talking about looks
because I said about being hot okay wait
let me reform I mean what I said is
being rich hot because if you see a lot
of these celebrities when they're
average people they were just average
when they're rich they're high wait wait
wait let me rephrase let me rephrase my
dear let me rephrase what doesn't give a
damn about your money so when you say
hang on So when you say if you get rich
you become hotter no she doesn't mean
her wealthy
all right fine but you said when you
become rich you'll become hotter right
no the richest money can buy me she's
she's saying she would get a
nutritionist
but the thing is you are still going to
be 30. yeah do you understand you're
still going to be 30. so let me I'm not
trying to pit women against each other
right yeah but we have Linda over here
who's 20 and a virgin yes and we have
you right you've you've been you've been
an abusive relationship you're 29 you've
gone through all this stuff and you're
if you if you say you're 8.5 let's just
say you and Linda are 8.5 right you're
both at 8.5 who do you think men are
going to choose it depends no it doesn't
depend I'm gonna go for the younger one
okay I want to say I want to say
something
wait you see I want to rephrase what he
said he said about old men giving uh
attention no no the beta simps that
those simps will give the average woman
or any woman attention by default
because they look at women as sexual
objects so you're literally gonna think
all that attention you're thinking oh
you know I'm paying but really it's
because the Sims just look at everything
just the gender if you're female they'll
just start giving you attention and this
is another problem number one it's naive
to think that I rely on my looks to get
in any anything in any situation with
men no way all my looks so okay okay
would you have gotten on the Castillo
dating show if you weren't pretty
um yeah okay I'll tell you something let
me tell you something my looks are my
secondary gift my first gift will be my
personality and the only reason why we
speak English
okay okay you
it would be naive to think that I rely
on my looks number one number two it
would be nice to think that I'm sitting
here trying to display to you guys why I
would want to be a wife to you I don't
want to be a wife if I wanted to be your
wife I would be speaking to you
differently because I want you to be my
man I don't have to to be treated
treating every single man like he's my
husband because he's a man my husband
I'm gonna cut you off okay no no Sarah
go ahead what no because she could like
you need to give other people so what
what I'm trying to say is
you don't understand how you first of
all self-reflection and introspection is
a thing right and I'm all about
self-reflection introspection
and for this whole conversation that
we've been having today I don't think
you've understood the way you've come
across I really don't and I think it's
I'm not a psychologist I'm not a
psychiatrist so you can you can throw
away what I'm saying you can say
whatever that guy's talking [__] right
but
the way in the things that are coming
out of your mouth are so contradictory
to the way you are acting it it is very
it is
it's a sight to behold I'm not gonna lie
like I I've done this show for I've been
on your show for what six months now
from the beginning right and I've no I'm
not gonna lie I've I've rarely met women
that have been that contradictory it's
not contradictory it's just simply that
you're not you're not understanding that
there's levels to this for example you
can pet me and it's Linda right yeah so
okay no no I'm not trying to pick you no
no I'll just give it an example I'm
going to give you another example and
this is why I say it depends she is
younger than me 10 years basically
because I'm 29. yeah she's a virgin I'm
not definitely right okay as a man who
do you think listen listen and this is
the problem why is age and why is
virginity something that makes you a
better wife and I'll tell you why this
is a question no no no no no okay okay
you asked her question can I answer it
so so the reason is because the more
sexual partners you have the less chance
you have of being as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible